-Performing her new single,
"You Only Love Me,"
once again, Rita Ora!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Rita, it's me.
-♪ I'm outside your house again,
freezin' in the cold ♪
♪ Waitin' for the moment
I learn to let go ♪
♪ I been messed up
a thousand times ♪
♪ With tears in my eyes ♪
♪ But all the pain,
it fades away ♪
♪ When you say it right ♪
♪ I try, I try, and I try ♪
♪ To tell myself it's alright ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm terrified ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ Whiskey's pourin' ♪
♪ Four in the mornin' ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ Night is over ♪
♪ No one to hold ya ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
Ha!
♪♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ I can't believe
you look at me ♪
♪ The way I look at you ♪
♪ 'Cause no one's ever
loved me back ♪
♪ The way that you do ♪
♪ I've been messed up
a thousand times ♪
♪ But you make it right ♪
♪ And even on my darkest days,
you show me the light ♪
♪ I try, I try, and I try ♪
♪ To tell myself it's alright ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm terrified ♪
♪ That you only love me
when the ♪
♪ Whiskey's pourin' ♪
♪ Four in the mornin' ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ Night is over ♪
♪ No one to hold ya ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
Ha!
♪♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ Whiskey's pourin' ♪
♪ Four in the mornin' ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
♪ Night is over ♪
♪ No one to hold ya ♪
♪ You only love, you only love ♪
♪ You only love me when the ♪
Ha!
-This is how I am.
This is how you are.
[ Cheers and applause ]